Estoy hablando de tiempo. Tu tiempo.
En efecto, creo que estemos en medio a una epidemia global
de una nueva enfermedad terrible llamada SAI [MAS]:
[Mindless Accept Syndrome]. Síndrome de la Aceptación Insensata
(Risas)
Los síntomas básicos del Síndrome de la Aceptación Insensata
es aceptar inmediatamente invitaciones
tan pronto surjan en tu calendario.
(Risas)
Es un reflejo involuntario; ding, clic, bing; está en tu calendario,
"Ya me tengo que ir, me retraso para una reunión." (Risas)
Las reuniones son importantes, ¿verdad?
Y la colaboración es clave para el éxito de una empresa.
Una reunión bien organizada
puede rendir resultados positivos y aplicables.
Pero en medio de la globalización
e informática omnipresente,
la manera como trabajamos
se cambió dramáticamente en los últimos años.
Y somos desgraciados. (Risas)
Somos desgraciados no porque
los otros no saben hacer una buena reunión,
sino debido al SAI, nuestro Síndrome de Aceptación Insensata,
que es una herida autoinfligida.
En verdad, puedo evidenciar que el SAI es una epidemia global.
Ya les digo por qué.
Hace algunos años, yo subí un vídeo en Youtube,
y en el vídeo representé todas las llamadas
terribles que suceden en conferencias.
Sigue así unos cinco minutos,
y contiene todo lo que detestamos de malas reuniones.
Hay el moderador que no tiene idea
de cómo moderar una reunión.
Están los participantes que no tienen idea
de por qué están allí.
Todo se da, en cierto modo,
como un descarrilamiento colaborativo.
Y todos se van enfadados.
Es un poco gracioso.
(Risas)
Echemos un rápido vistazo.
(Vídeo) Nuestra meta hoy es llegar
a un acuerdo en una importantísima propuesta.
Como grupo debemos decidir...
blup blup...
Hola, ¿quién se conectó?
Hola, soy Joe. Estoy trabajando desde casa hoy.
(Risas)
Hola, Joe. Gracias por acompañarnos aquí, genial.
Decía, tenemos mucha gente convocada,
omitamos así pasar lista
y ya voy a comenzar.
Nuestra meta hoy es llegar a un acuerdo
en una propuesta importantísima.
Como grupo debemos decidir si...
blup, blup...
(Risas)
Hola, ¿quién se conectó?
¿Nadie? Me pareció haber oído un bip. (Risas)
¿Les suena familiar?
Sí, a mí me suena familiar también.
Unas semanas tras haber subido el vídeo,
500 mil personas de docenas de países,
sí, de docenas de países,
vieron el vídeo.
Y tres años después, aún se ve cientos de veces al mes.
Está llegando a un millón ahora mismo.
Y algunas de las mayores empresas del mundo,
empresas que Uds. conocen pero no las nombraré,
me pidieron permiso
para usar este vídeo como formación de nuevos trabajadores
para enseñarles cómo no conducir una reunión en la empresa.
Y si los números...
—un millón de visualizaciones y todas esas empresas—
no son prueba suficiente
de que reuniones son un problema global,
hay aún muchos miles
de comentarios publicados en línea
después de que el vídeo hubiese sido publicado.
Miles de personas escribieron cosas como:
"Dios mío ¡mi día hoy fue lo mismo!"
"¡Era igual todos los días!"
"Es mi vida."
Un tipo escribió: "Es gracioso porque es verdad.
La verdad inquietante, triste y deprimente.
Me hizo reír hasta llorar.
Y lloré. Y lloré un poco más."
(Risas)
Este pobre hombre dijo:
"Mi vida diaria hasta la jubilación o la muerte. Suspiro."
Son citas reales y es muy triste.
Un tema común que surge en todos esos comentarios en línea
es esta creencia fundamental en nuestra impotencia
para cualquiera otra cosa que no sea ir a reuniones
y sufrir con estas reuniones mal conducidas
y vivir para cumplir un día más.
Pero la verdad es que no somos de manera alguna impotentes.
De hecho, el remedio del SAI está en nuestras manos.
Literalmente al alcance de nuestras manos.
Es algo que llamo ¡No SAI! [No MAS]
(Risas)
Que si no recuerdo mal a mi profesora de español,
significa algo como: [No MAS] "¡Basta, ya!"
Como funciona el No MAS SAI . Es muy simple.
Primero, la próxima vez que Uds. reciban una invitación
sin mucha información en sí,
hagan clic en el botón de provisional.
Está bien, pueden hacerlo, por eso está allá.
Está al lado del botón de Aceptar.
Es el botón Quizás o cualquier botón
existente para no aceptar inmediatamente.
Después, pónganse en contacto
con quien les invitó a la reunión.
Díganle de su entusiasmo para respaldar su trabajo,
pregúntenle cuál es el objetivo de la reunión,
y díganle que les gustaría saber
cómo pueden ayudarlo a alcanzar su objetivo.
Y si lo hacemos frecuentemente, y con respecto,
quizás se vuelven los otros más concienzudos
sobre como crean las invitaciones.
Y Uds. pueden decidir más concienzudamente si las aceptan.
Pueden incluso mismo empezar a enviar programas. ¡Imaginen!
O pueden no convocar una conferencia
con 12 personas para hablar de un estatus,
si pueden tan solo
enviar un corto e-mail y resolverlo luego.
Los otros pueden empezar a cambiar su comportamiento
a causa de sus cambios.
Y quizás incluso le devuelvan la silla. (Risas)
¡No MAS SAI!
Gracias.
(Aplausos)